my name is El wit I'm a model and I also
have a youtube channel my name is
Alexandra
I am mum I work in the testing industry
and I write about mental health how old
were you when you first started feeling
depressed
well my parents got divorced when I was
seven and then I had some pretty bad
times and so I went to all-girls
boarding school
getting to know people was hard ya know
he it was when I told me like nine I
probably would say when it all decides
getting bad but I never really realize
until I was 13 probably yeah what about
you I was probably like 12 my parents
divorced so all of a sudden they were
splitting up I was moving house I was
moving schools I was a teenager so
probably going through puberty like the
worst time ever and I think it was just
completely overwhelming school was
difficult I didn't want to get out of
bed
my my parents didn't know what to do
with me I had problems with drugs and
like self-harm and just hanging about
with the wrong people just feeling
isolated and disconnected it was like a
huge part of depression for me and just
not not feeling like I could talk to
anyone and not really wanting to talk to
anyone for a while as well when my
parents were divorced I was so angry at
everyone around because no one would
listen
yeah no one was like sorry text mesh
like you okay yeah you know to another
school and then I tried really hard for
him and people there but that wasn't
Bristol and I was like away from
somewhere else and I think that's where
it kind of all got bad like inked
sorters anxiety couldn't talk to anyone
left school mess call up it was like and
then it just saw goes downhill when did
you first realize that you might need
help I remember being like ten and being
really angry like I mean not just like
I'm angry
and then I would have my anxiety attacks
the point why I'd like scream and hurt
myself and it looked like people like a
tantrum but literally it was trying to
rip myself out of my own skin and I
think it wasn't until I was like 14 15
I'd like tried to kill myself and then
my dad was like you needs to get help
now but when you're a teenager you don't
really think about actually getting help
and then going to see someone because a
mess of someone talks to you about the
fact that is help available don't know
yeah I mean I feel like as a kid when
you're growing up and like going for you
puberty it's like hard to talk about
things anyway like you're constantly
feeling like a bit embarrassed and you
want to be cool with your friends so
talking about you know having those
types of feelings makes you feel like a
complete outsider and you're just
constantly kind of pretending everything
is fine when evidently it's not and the
more you kind of repress those feelings
the worse things get but eventually like
my panic attacks got so bad and
everything just I felt so alone and even
more isolated that that's when I tried
to kill myself as well so it's
demobilizing like it's something that
just completely makes you feel unable to
cope or do anything all I wanted to do
like going through that time my life was
fit in and be like everyone else but the
more I tried to be like everyone else
the more apparently it became that I
just wasn't you feel like worthless in
that sense they're like you're not worth
anything to anyone everything's gonna go
bad at all times it's like the end of
the world every day a part of coming to
terms of depression is like not feel
feeling guilty for like speeding this
way yeah you ghost your friends and you
feel like you're they're gonna like get
you out the hole pull you out and you
they can't do that yeah only you can do
that whether any treatments or
medications that you use that help you
so I was put on sertraline eventually
about a years since I was 13 years old
on-off on-off
cuz every time I tried to get off the
medicine I just started to feel worse I
started to feel really depressed I
wouldn't we started getting suicidal
feelings it made it harder in the long
run to actually deal with what was going
on for me but being off medicine for a
year now and I would say for me
personally I would try not to be put on
medicine I think that it's a really
quick fix at times like it's great for
temporarily like if you're going for a
really bad spell from personal
experience if you can go down a more
holistic route or just get counseling or
do meditation or do anything that can
help you like manage those feelings
better I would always say do that I
think I've been unlike all of them that
they give out and it is the first thing
that they say is takes antidepressants
but you doesn't solve the root of the
problem no but they wait for counseling
and the NHS is so in over demanded yeah
for mental health services and their
services get cut and there's like
nothing left to help people I think it's
obviously important to realize that
everyone is so different so obviously
charleen era and there are so many
different kinds of ways that you could
possibly help yourself but it's just
being aware of what they are if
counseling isn't for you there's
something else start exercising do you
know I mean like it's not gonna get rid
of all like the traumas but it's gonna
help you like booster endorphines and
you're gonna start to feel like maybe
you can start to think about things more
naive enough of the medicine through
year what's the most helpful to you I
feel depressed and anxious all the time
it's not something that just goes away I
think it's something that you learn to
kind of cope with her managed better if
you can find like one positive thing by
every single day even if it wasn't one
of the best days of one thing and go do
you know what today I did this or today
I met that person they were great or I
learnt this like just focusing on one
good thing for a day I actually stopped
taking medication last year I got a
happy
no help as of the crisis team I just
pretended to be super happy over time I
mean and stop drinking and I haven't
drank since yeah I think it's really
positive that we're both a place where
it's managed even though like so you
know a new short circuit something then
the backup generator comes up yeah
that's how I feel I can cope with it now
and not lose control completely
you have everything that's not safe
there power of the mind yeah like it's
so powerful self to think you're a cat
attacked me so if you can sound stupid
but actually pretend and actually like
not pretend as in don't talk about
anything that's pretend very okay but
like smile and like tell yourself you
think you're awesome like eventually you
can kind of start to train your brain
you pick up on that war it's very easy
to tell someone to like do something or
do CBT or do this but it's not as easy
to actually put that into action and
start doing it seeing other people
sharing their stories definitely helps
yes I wish that when I was like 16 years
old I could see someone that I looked up
to talking about it openly online
because being depressed makes you feel
disconnected from people makes you feel
completely alone and so for me now I'm
like older and more comfortable with
that part of myself like I want to talk
about it if I didn't have a support
network I would be able to find
something that year or like me even if I
didn't have a support I could probably
just message that person be like that
you've really helped me and I think you
know there is something you might not
have a support network but you can find
support and other places yeah that is
one good thing about the internet if you
can just makes one person not feel alone
then it's like worth it job done yeah
thanks for watching we hope you found
this helpful if you want to see more
videos like this you can go to the
glamour UK youtube channel
[Music]